vanda high they're up and around they're
conducting other business
outside of shkaplerov and dubrov who as
i mentioned a moment ago are inside the
zvezda service module
monitoring the approach of prishall at
the ready to take over manual control in
the unlikely event an issue would occur
with the core's automated rendezvous
system
uh
marshburn baron and vanda hi
later today along with matthias moore
will be conducting a spacewalk procedure
conference with flight controllers here
in houston in advance of next tuesday's
spacewalk by tom marshburn and caleb
barron that will begin at 6 10 a.m
central time 7 10 a.m eastern time to
replace a faulty s-ban communications
antenna system on the port 1 truss of
the international space station we'll
talk more about that later in the
broadcast
this view now of the engineering data on
the external camera of the progress
delivery craft attached to prishall
showing in the far uh in the bottom left
hand corner the
distance between prishal and progress
and the international space station now
just over seven kilometers separating
the uh arriving pre-shawl module and the
station closing at a rate of just under
10 meters per second
is complete
copy that
now for builder better
you can activate recording um since uh
we're already getting
a video image from both mlm and progress
so
this is a perfect time to
press recording and start recording the
entire
sequence
copy
starting recording in the works
again russian flight controllers uh
you're hearing the interpretation of
their conversations with russian
cosmonauts anton shkaplerov and piotr
dubrov
on board the international space station
actively monitoring the approach of
prishal to the complex
you just saw an external uh hd camera
view
from international space station cameras
as the station
approaches uh the coast of chile and the
andes mountains
moving from southwest to northeast
and
the
recording field is showing that
recording is in progress
and
the
time is incrementing
copy putter thank you very much
in just a few minutes there will be a
test
of the command link
from shkaplerov and dubrov of the
tele-robotically operated rendezvous
system
as they send
test signals basically to the on-board
systems of the presale
node module and the progress delivery
craft that is attached to prusal
this will verify that we have a good
backup rendezvous system in the event a
problem would occur with the core's
automated rendezvous system so far cores
is operating solidly providing all of
the updated navigational information to
the progress's onboard computers
you can see uh traversing uh
the river along
chile's mountains
that white dot you see that is the uh
prashal module and the progress resupply
or delivery craft in this case
as priscile in progress approach the
five kilometer mark away from the
international space station
preschool in progress now crossing the
pampas of argentina
will pass just to the west of buenos
aires on this pass
a good view of the progress delivery
craft in the prashal node module
flying over argentina
moving inexorably towards its docking to
the international space station less
than 40 minutes from now
there will be a series of so-called
impulse burns those are small engine
firings on the progress delivery craft
it essentially uh is a propulsion module
for the prashal
node those impulse burns are small
engine firings to fine-tune the
vehicle's path to the international
space station we're about 15 minutes
away
from the
new presale
entering the neighborhood of the
international space station for its fly
around
and its alignment to the nader or
earth-facing port of the naoka
multipurpose laboratory module
priscile in progress now crossing the
border between argentina and uruguay
and there's our first first view of the
international space station from
external cameras on presale in progress
now three kilometers separating the new
module from its final destination
closing at a rate of eight meters per
second
pershall in progress and now have moved
uh
across uruguay now flying 260 miles over
southern brazil
range rate
and rotation started
and a good view of the new presale node
module and the attached progress
instrumentation and propulsion
compartment
the new module right on course for a
docking schedule 35 minutes from now
again
the node module consists of six docking
ports one of which will be employed
to link up to the naoka multipurpose
laboratory module
five radial ports
will then be available to accommodate
future
unpiloted progress resupply vehicles and
piloted soyuz spacecraft
we have a rotation in rivers and a 5 uh
decimal five five range is two
kilometers
we're watching uh the reverse maneuver
arrange rate for decimal 23 uh range
rate 1.76
uh we give you a go to activate
cases
to activate torah
anton we give you a go to activate toro
copy uh your go to activate to where
we're activating toro
majestically framed against the limb of
the earth the priscile node module and
the progress
instrumentation and propulsion
compartment
flying uh just to the northwest of rio
de janeiro uh we're actually
performing tour
[Music]
one and a half kilometers separating a
presale from the international space
station closing at a rate of four meters
per second
about eight and a half minutes
from beginning its fly around of the
complex
that you see in this view from the
external camera on progress
closing in
right on course and right on track for
its docking
we release the push button i'm
activating the network
we uh have the power network of the hand
controllers uh activating web is input
initial
all right activating vps
we have internal power on
copy i am preparing the hand controllers
yes start the test the hand controller
test
the hand controllers are on we are
starting hand controller
uh test
for attitude moving and controller up
we see all four eliminated
no longer eliminated
motion down
four leds are eliminated
ah neutral position uh no longer
eliminated moving to the left
russian flight controllers continuing to
provide situational awareness for anton
shkaplerov the iss commander and
his fellow russian cosmonaut piero
dubrov inside the zvezda service module
they've just conducted a test of the
tele-robotically operated rendezvous
system
a backup system to the core's automated
rendezvous system that is currently
guiding priscilla in progress toward the
naoka multipurpose laboratory module
here in mission control in houston
flight director rick henfling shortly
will uh conduct a poll of his flight
controllers to get a go no-go for final
approach and docking he then will relay
that to his russian shift flight
controller our flight director
counterpart at the russian mission
control center outside of moscow down
internal and external are
on neutral position
no longer eliminated to the left
external and internal or on neutral
position
no longer eliminated
uh to the right external and internal
are on
the switch pulling the switch down
internal and external are
on released no longer eliminated pushing
it away from myself
internal and external or on neutral
position no longer eliminated
hand controller test is without issues
copy
thank you the reports are all good uh
all of preschool's systems all the
progress is systems in perfect shape so
far
now 800 meters separating the new module
from the international space station
closing at a rate of two meters per
second okay copy no longer eliminated
work for item uh 12 decimal 3 starting
on item 12 3.
vape is in the initial
position
activating operation
turned on the operation
and flight director rick henfling has
completed his poll of flight controllers
all positions here are go for docking
the international space station in
prashal now flying 260 miles just off
the northeast coast of south america
you can set the video that is
comfortable for you
we feel comfortable i have
access to
i have set up the comfortable position
okay copy i have
turned off the operation and now before
these are not on copy
i am going to go to page 92
i'll continue the approach
arrange speaking simultaneously
one arrangement one five five
work for page 92 from the start of the
fly round copy i'm on page 92
and as you heard
everything is all set for the beginning
of the 54 degree fly around of brisall
in progress
to align
the new module
with the
nader docking port the earth-facing
docking port of the naoka multipurpose
laboratory module
the reports are at the 500 meter mark
separating
prishal and the international space
station all systems are in perfect shape
copying
range is 400 and the power
activation confirmed so we confirmed for
a round copy
and the report uh right on target uh the
fly around of priscile in progress
of the international space station now
underway
365 meters separating
the new module from the international
space station and again you can see
the fly around as it is being conducted
from the external engineering camera on
the progress delivery craft
range
is 300 meters range rate one uh
decibel three eight
exactly where priscile in progress are
supposed to be at this point of the fly
around
which should be completed shortly
at a distance of about 200
meters at which point there'll be a
brief period of station keeping
visually and
uh verified the course
uh readings using the scale uh okay it's
about
one and a half uh squares is the range
okay copy
oh it's slightly bigger than one
square it's about one decimal two
squares
per scale
okay copy that it matches
approaching the west coast of africa now
240 meters separating priscilla in
progress from the international space
station's naoka
module closing at a rate of two-tenths
of a meter per second
stick originally
the
docking module is slightly
bigger than one
square
copy
[Music]
keeping antonio
okay in 17 minutes copy
the docking
module is within one degree
copy
i am uh
watching the
maneuver the role maneuver
copy
this roll maneuver now underway will
properly align the solar arrays
on the progress instrumentation and
propulsion compartment
into the right orientation for final
approach contact and capture
200 meters separating priscile from
naoka
crossing the border now between
mauritania and morocco
range is one nine zero
watching
the maneuver coughing
and operations
this is mission control houston a great
view of the node module the preschool
the brand new module and the final
element of the russian segment of the
international space station
the russian flight controllers wasted
little time giving a go for final
approach after just a few seconds of
station keeping
so we're in the final phase of this
rendezvous with docking scheduled about
17 minutes from now
led or no oh these are no longer
eliminated
copy
uh
page 93 monitoring automatic approach a
copy working for page 93.
uh within two degrees
uh range
rate is
160 and range rate is
negative
0.8
i
confirm
that the dimensions are aligned and the
range is about 150
copy
coming up on the 100 meter mark
separating uh prishal and naoka you can
see the circular docking port of the
multipurpose laboratory module just
below the crosshairs in this external
engineering camera on the progress
delivery craft
closing at a rate of about six tenths of
a meter per second now
flying just to the south of casablanca
are the ranges showing 100 meters
copy range is 100 meters
target is
uh is uh towards the bottom by two
degrees and crosstails are aligned
copy
10 minutes until eclipse
the headlight is on
copy
copy the headlight is on
sm is
showing ranges about 75 75
range rate is 0 3 3 the target is the
same towards the bottom bunch of degrees
and crosstails are aligned
copying
65 meters now separating priscile this
great view of the new node module and
the attached progress delivery craft
as the combination
sales 263 statute miles off the northern
coast of africa over the mediterranean
mcc moscow the range is about 40 meters
for the measurement
it's 46 for a course measurement
uh range is
0.17 and the target is towards the
bottom by 2 degrees do you see the video
yes i see the video
we have we see the video
we see the message uh that is right
forward docking probe on preschool has
been extended uh the docking system is
now active
some 12 minutes away from contact and
capture
do not send command over container is
retracted okay copying
our range is about 30 meters i am
turning
off
initial operation copy
flying just north of rome and soon to
enter an orbital sunset
the node module now just 30 meters away
from its final port of call
uh the target is towards the bottom uh
by about two degrees uh the crosshairs
are aligned coffee
our range is about 20
to zero
copy continue
we can
continue monitoring the automatic
approach
we see some
interferences in the video uh and now
the video is restored copying
five minutes into eclipse
one
about 18 meter range
okay we see a little bit of a row we see
the target towards the bottom within two
degrees coffee all of those reports to
anton shkaplerov and piotr dubrov on the
international space station indicating a
perfect alignment
of the preschools forward docking probe
that you can see in this view
as it is about to pass behind the solar
array
on a soyuz vehicle that is docked nearby
at the rassvet module of the
international space station
now 15 meters separating prishal from
naoka
closing at a rate of 1 10th of a meter
per second
i work i'm working with agc mode i see
crosshairs being misaligned i see the
target uh the roll is about 30 30
degrees
copy about two cells
the range is about eight meters the
target is to the left by about
three degrees
copying
uh the misalignment is increasing
three degrees to the left we're going
with the
row bias of 30.
uh two and a half cells the range is
about 6 meters
i'll continue monitoring the automatic
approach until it
it's more by
then it's
more than four cells okay six meters
away now
three degrees to the
um
left and bottom now about two degrees
core's final alignment
is taking over
standing by for contact and capture
about one meter
three degrees to the left to the bottom
to the bottom one degree we
have contact
contact confirmed
and capture confirmed at 9 19 a.m
central time
10 19 a.m eastern time
as prishal and the international space
station flew 262 miles over ukraine
so a holiday season delivery of a new
module to complete the russian segment
of the international space station now
complete
and
uh door rejection the docking probe now
retracting this will pull the two
docking interfaces flush against one
another to enable the initiation of the
closing of hooks and latches
copy
once again the new module the node
module a multi-port
docking
venue for future progress resupply craft
and piloted soyuz vehicles
now part of the international space
station you can see it there docked to
the earth-facing port of the naoka
multipurpose laboratory module
having been delivered by the progress
instrumentation and propulsion module
that is attached to prishal
and which will undock
on december 21st to be deorbited to burn
up in the earth's atmosphere leaving the
node module of course as a permanent
fixture on the international space
station
docking occurring once again
at 9 19 a.m central time
10 19 a.m eastern time
as prushal and the international space
station flew over ukraine
the
hooks on the prashal module now in the
process of closing to form a hard mate
between the newly arrived module
and naoka
this is mission control houston hooks
are now closed
forming a hard mate between the new
prishal module the russian word for peer
the new multi port
docking
venue for multiple uh progress and soyuz
vehicles of the future
priscile arriving at the international
space station about six minutes ago at 9
19 a.m central time 10 19 a.m eastern
time
linking up to the earth-facing port
of the
naoka multipurpose laboratory module
having been delivered to the station by
a modified progress instrumentation and
propulsion craft that will separate from
prishal on december 21st
leaving the node module as a permanent
fixture to the russian segment of the
international space station
it was as flawless a rendezvous as you
can have
no issues from the time of its launch
two days ago from the baikonur
cosmodrome in kazakhstan
arriving flawlessly
after an uneventful uh journey
on the 34 orbits from the launch pad in
baikonur to the international space
station
this uh newly arrived node module the
prashal
will be integrated into the russian
segment of the station during a russian
space walk
by anton shkaplerov and peoria dubrov on
january 19th
when they will spend about six and a
half hours outside hooking up the core's
automated rendezvous
connections and television cable
connections
also will install docking targets and
handrails
and remove
other antennas that will be jettisoned
no longer needed now that prishal is
attached to the international space
station
i wanted to check do i execute item 11
only or
do i need to do item 10 as well
so with priscile having uh flawlessly
and successfully docked to the naoka
module of the international space
station
there's more activity on tap next week
at the international outpost let's take
a quick look
next up a spacewalk by nasa astronauts
tom marshburn and kayla barron
to replace a faulty s-band
communications antenna on the port one
truss of the international space station
we will preview that spacewalk u.s
spacewalk number 78
in a briefing here at the johnson space
center next monday
at 1 pm central time 2 p.m eastern time
on nasa television
the spacewalk itself is scheduled for
tuesday november 30th a planned six and
a half hour excursion
out of the quest airlock of the
international space station by marshburn
and barron that will begin
our coverage will begin at 4 30 a.m
central 5 30 a.m eastern time with the
spacewalk itself
to get underway at about 6 10 central
time 7 10 a.m eastern time
so with that we'll wrap up our coverage
for today the prashal node module now
hard mated to the naoka multipurpose
laboratory module after a perfect
two-day rendezvous following its launch
from the baikonur cosmodrome in
kazakhstan
with that we'll conclude for the day we
hope you have a great rest of the
holiday weekend and we'll see you back
here next week for spacewalk coverage
this is mission control houston
[Music]
you